at this hour
our democracy is under unprecedented
assault
unlike anything we've seen in modern
times
an assault on the citadel of liberty
the capitol itself
an assault on the people's
representatives
and the capitol hill police sworn to
protect them
and the public servants who work
at the heart of our republic
an assault on the rule of law
like few times we've ever seen it
assault on the most sacred of american
undertakings
the doing of the people's business
let me be very clear the scenes of chaos
at the capitol
do not reflect a true america
do not represent who we are
what we're seeing are a small number of
extremists
dedicated to lawlessness this is not
dissent
it's disorder it's chaos
it borders on sedition and it must end
now
i call on this mob to pull back and
allow the work of democracy to go
forward you've heard me say before in
different contexts
the words of a president matter
no matter how good or bad that president
is
at their best the words of a president
can inspire
their worst they can incite
i know your pain i know you're hurt
we had an election that was stolen
from us it was a landslide election
and everyone knows it especially the
other side
but you have to go home now we have to
have peace
we have to have law and order we have to
respect our great
people in law and order we don't want
anybody hurt
it's a very tough period of time there's
never been a time like this where
such a thing happened where they could
take it away from all of us
from me from you from our country this
was a fraudulent
election but we can't play into the
hands
of these people we have to have peace
so go home we love you you're very
special
you've seen what happens you see the way
others are treated that are
so bad and so evil i know how you feel
but go home and go home at peace
you